so in the last video we did our circuit
analysis we set up the four equations
that we needed
to solve in order to figure out all the
voltages and currents
in our in our example circuit and so now
we're going to solve it
this is a matter of doing the algebra to
solve a set of four simultaneous
equations
what i want to do now is just write my
equations down here and and tidy them up
a little bit so the first one we're
going to bring down
is the voltage statement here which i
can write as
v1
plus
v2
equals
vs
i'm going to bring down the i
equation over here it's going to be
i1
minus i2
equals is
and now i have to pick i have i have
four variables here i'm going to start
doing substitutions
based on these expressions up here these
are my ohm's law expressions so we're
going to use those to substitute for the
voltages and we're going to solve the
whole thing in terms of currents
so the first equation
becomes v1 is
r1i1
plus
r2
i2
equals vs
second equation stays the same i1
minus i2
equals is
the next step in the solution is going
to be to figure out how to eliminate one
of these currents
now i think what i'll do is i'll
eliminate
i2 and i can do that if i multiply
this equation
by
r2
and
add these equations together so let's do
the multiplication by r2 first
we'll rewrite the first equation up here
r1 i1
plus r2
i2
equals
vs
and then down the bottom equation is
going to be
r2
i1
minus r2
i2
equals r2
is
we're going to add these equations
together
and we can see these terms nicely cancel
out
and so i'm going to end up with
r1
plus r2
times i1
equals
vs
plus
r2
is
and i can get the solution in symbolic
terms for i1
i1
equals
vs plus r2
is over
r1 plus r2
what i want to do now is actually put in
the original
real values and solve this circuit all
the way through
so we'll move up and keep going
so let me sketch the the circuit again
the real circuit again we had a voltage
source
with 15 volts
it went to a
4k resistor
that was r1
we had a 2k resistor here
and a current source
and that was 3 milliamps
and we want to discover
this was i1
and this was i2
those are the two unknown currents let's
see if we can find those so
i1
equals vs
plus
r2 is 2k
times is
3 milliamps
divided by
4k
plus
2k
so let's solve this that equals
plus
2k times 2k times 3 milliamps is
6 volts
this is volts
and that's divided by
4 plus 6
k
equals
21 volts over 6 k
3.5
milli
amps
so that's this value right here
3.5
milliamps
is i1
so we have one of our unknown currents
and we want to find the other one
that's sitting right here
we can figure out i2 so
minus i2
equals
is
minus i1
equals
3 milliamps
minus
3.5 milliamps
equals
minus 0.5
let's get rid of the minus signs i2
equals
0.5
milliamps
that's that value right there
let's put some boxes around our answers
we have so far
here's one
and here's another one there's i2 and i1
and now let's finish up by figuring out
the voltages
we can use ohm's law to figure out the
voltage across the 4k resistor and
that's v1 so v1
equals i which is 3.5
milliamps times 4k
4k ohms
and that equals
three and a half times four is
volts
whenever you multiply milli amps times k
ohms those units cancel and you get
volts
so v1
equals 14 volts
and our last current or sorry our last
voltage is v2 is the voltage right here
and v2
equals i2 which we decided was point
5 milliamp
times
2000 ohms 2k
and v2
equals
one
volt
and now we've solved our circuit that's
a complete circuit analysis using the
fundamental laws